how many screenplays have you written
probably around
17 or 18.
yeah and these are feature length or oh
it's a mix uh Pilots as well as features
probably
actually mostly features Maybe
five Pilots
is your process always the same
no no my process changes with every
script although recently I think I've
found my process that really works but
in the beginning it was like I was
trying different processes to see what
works best for me like I've done the
note cards
um I've done where I just start with a
blank page and just start writing a
script
um
but now I think what works for me is
I'll start with a treatment
and then from that
I'll go to a script like a first draft
and then from there I'll go back to
treatment because a lot of times I'm
going to a script
really just to explore because a lot of
times the ideas come to me as I'm
writing an actual scene
and I'll start figuring out things after
I've sort of done a vomit draft
then I'll start seeing okay these are
the characters and this is what I'm
really trying to do
but then I kind of throw that away and
then you know in order to throw that
away I have to go back to an actual
blank page and I'll start with the
treatment again because a lot of times
things might change around
structurally and all that
for some of the screenplays that you've
written that maybe take place in more of
a underworld or criminal element did you
ever immerse yourself in let's say you
know a bar in a bad part of town and
just to kind of soak up the feeling
yeah I mean
well when I was
um making a Las Vegas story so like the
the woman who plays the lead actress you
know is it it's pretty much like about
her actual life story
um and she was actually a friend of mine
you know before we made the movie so she
took me to like some random places like
very um Shady
I guess clubs or you know
and I met like a bunch of
interesting characters I should put it
that way
um
but yeah I definitely try to put myself
out there to understand like what the
texture is you know of this world and
how those characters talk
for bang bang I already knew a bunch of
like Asian gangsters so I already kind
of had that mapped out in my head but
even for that movie I put real gangsters
in the movie like Ty viji he's a real
gangster rapper but he's actually a real
gangster
um so for that you know
I think my research was already done
but
yeah I would like to put myself out
there as much as I can I think I mean I
think as a writer you should you know to
really get an authentic feel even if
you're going to go away from that
um to know what
the real world is like and then you can
write more of a you know exaggerated or
Fantastical version of it
so one world you kind of sort of already
knew or you saw from from the outside in
another world A friend brought you into
and you were yeah sort of a fly on the
wall yeah some interesting places did
you ask questions or you just observed
I was
I I had a few meetings with people and I
would tell them like hey I'm writing a
movie and uh and like you know it'll be
an actual interview like they would tell
me all these stories and this happened
to them
um and then there would be times when we
went to a location or a place and I
would just hang out you know
um and just watch what do you tell
yourself before you began a screenplay
or a film tell myself you better really
like the story because it's going to be
painful
um that's kind of like the truth you
know I
question myself I was like Hey like what
kind of a story are you trying to tell
here why are you writing this
um what is interesting about this story
or world or character
and
and that's kind of like where I really
just go from you know and at a certain
point if I lose interest in it then I
stop writing it
so do you test yourself will I want to
stay committed to this for three years
and if I don't if I'm having any doubts
I don't really set like us a time limit
like that but I'll constantly go back to
like what's interesting about this to me
um
because if I'm not interested in anymore
then
is really difficult to write something
well for Bang Bang
what kept you going the entire time
I was interested in the dynamic of
a rich kid trying to be a gangster
and then
really it came from that of like a
person from a rich family
kind of like put into a gangster
lifestyle and why would somebody
want want to do that because I saw that
in real life with a lot of people you
know in my neighborhood where they came
from really nice families really rich
families but they were just trying to be
like the hardest gangster out there
but yeah I just I think that was just
the driving force of like me trying to
understand like why or what does this
look like
the friendships the Dynamics and what
are some
you know situations that could happen
yeah and maybe by
being The Bad Seed they were getting
back at their parents or whatever it was
and maybe they didn't feel at home in
that world from people that I've met
that did similar they never really felt
like they fit in
yeah a lot of um and with the character
in bang bang his family I mean he's
considered a parachute kid which is like
the parents kind of just drop you off in
a foreign country in America and then
they go and do business in Taiwan or
wherever
um so the kid was left alone a lot
um with a beamer like a BMW all the
money he wants big mansion but like
there's no guidance and no discipline so
what do you think is going to happen to
this kid who is also looking for love
and acceptance and if he has the money
in the cars that's the first way that he
can get accepted right oh he's the guy
with a cool car okay well what what's
gonna come after that he needs to prove
to other people he's not just a rich kid
that he's also like down with the
streets like he's trying to prove
something because he's trying to fill up
a void in his um life
and then but you're also drawn to the to
the poor character or more working class
and their struggles which are yeah yeah
I'm drawn to that character because you
know that's kind of how I grew up you
know me and my mom we really didn't have
much growing up uh we lived in a studio
apartment sleeping on the floor uh like
I slept on the floor probably most of my
middle school and high school life and I
was perfectly fine with that I actually
like the hard floor it's giving me back
yeah yeah it's really good for your back
um
but yeah you know I
I was drawn to that struggle of like
just not having much but
you're trying to get out of that you
know trying to do better for yourself
um
did you have brothers and sisters I have
a stepbrother yeah or I'm a half brother
okay
so wow so you that was your bedroom was
the floor in the studio yeah right yeah
I knew I knew people like that too and
and I grew up in an apartment as well so
a makeshift curtain divided a room yeah
so it sounds like uh it sounds like that
was a more personal story for you but
with Las Vegas story
um what was it that Drew you into those
characters because it looks like it's a
very interesting character yeah that
story I was really it was really from um
my friend Christina
um like I was drawn to her story like
her life story and how she's an
incredible mom to her um
four kids and and how she
was able to do that you know and
and just her struggle right like how
does she
deal with all that like the stuff that
she goes through and and still be able
to provide a great life for her children
um
and I think just like the world of Vegas
something about it was like
it's kind of surreal to me you know like
we go there and suddenly you're not
living by
Norms you're just like oh and everyone's
trying to be somebody they're not people
are just spending money or losing money
losing their entire lives in the casinos
and they make it seem so fake but so
happy just like
I don't know it's just like a strange
place and I kind of want to tell a story
in that world
do you have a voice that encourages you
or Nags at you
when you start something I know you said
earlier do I really want to do this but
is is there a voice are you battling any
any dual voices one that's telling you
this is going to be great I can't wait
and the other one's saying
don't screw this up
there's definitely a part of that going
on
but I I don't think for me is that
distinct
I think there's always some doubt you
know usually for me I start off with I
write the script and then I think it's
like the best thing ever
and then
slowly that feeling goes away as then I
start doubting myself like is this that
great like maybe you should have
somebody read it you know and then
depending on what people say I'll really
take that feedback like the first
feedback is somebody saying oh this is
great the number and be like oh my God I
got it I'll have a million dollar script
right here but if somebody's like oh I
don't know or they don't respond super
positively then I start having
self-doubts
so yeah definitely like back and forth
but it's really kind of like a gradual
voice I guess
do you have a group of people that you
trust that you send your scripts to yeah
I mean not a big group um I have a few
people like filmmaker friends writer
friends that um I'll send my stuff to
but I also use
um some like Consultants like or I guess
these websites like Wii screenplay
or um and I have a couple like private
Consultants that I use where they'll
give me like very you know in-depth
feedback
so maybe more
unbiased or I don't know or biased what
do you think when you when you pay for
the services of someone it's
it's more biased or unbiased
um I think it's it's a little bit
unbiased because you know if you show it
to a friend or a writer friend sometimes
um
they might not
necessarily give it to you straight you
know because they're also excited for
you maybe I mean there's a lot of
influences right but with a consultant
and you have to kind of be careful like
who you pick but um
yeah they'll usually
tell you if it's not really working for
them but I always take multiple um
feedbacks before I really kind of like
accept
what the bigger picture is
how do you create authenticity in your
screen please I think a lot of it is
research
but now I really think
authenticity it really comes from an
understanding of human nature
and
that's really what it comes down to like
are you telling
a story about characters who are
real right and in order to do that you
have to understand how people will react
or
or why people do certain things
um so if you don't understand that then
you're just creating caricatures that
you've seen in another movie for example
um so to really create like authenticity
I really think it comes from like a deep
understanding of human nature which for
me it really didn't
happened until just a few years ago like
I was telling you
um just through my own like experiences
and
and you know kind of like looking back
in my own psyche and my own life
um you start understanding a lot about
like you know how things from your
childhood affect you now you know some
impulses
um stuff like that can affect you now
and and you start seeing that in like
other people too right people who have
problems or you know dealing with
hardships
but you've traveled the world correct or
you've been overseas um I've traveled a
little bit Yeah so you've seen you know
different things and you said as a kid
maybe or teenager you had a little more
freedom than someone who had a curfew uh
I can only watch one channel yeah I knew
those kids too that's the one thing I
would say as well that um you gotta just
get out there and explore
um see the world meet different people
um I think the biggest influence well
maybe not the biggest but definitely a
big part when I was living in Germany I
was an English teacher
and I would teach
all sorts of people like it wasn't just
Germans um I had students who were from
Syria who were from Algeria
um Afghanistan because like a lot of
them they came as refugees and you know
once they learned German they had to
learn English because if you don't know
English then it's actually quite
difficult for you to get a job out in
Germany
so and I would spend hours every day
talking to these people like the way you
teach language is you sure you teach
them the grammar but at a certain point
it's just about speaking like ask
question they answer they ask me a
question I answer and then you just
start telling each other and like I've
learned so much about these people to
the point where it was like
even one of them was telling me they're
like wow this is kind of like therapy
like I just tell you everything about my
life or problems
that would make a great film actually
yeah yeah I mean it will be a two-hour
film just in a classroom talking but
or you know there could be an arc to the
character maybe the teacher goes for
their own reason and then they end up
being changed by these students who
either had equal or more greater
hardship you know and they all kind of
become their own makeshift family so
yeah yeah yeah I've thought about that
just gotta you know
pieces together right right I mean if
you will suppose you wanted to make
something that was close to your heart
are you going to
keep little distributor voice in the
back saying okay do we have a star in
this or is it more about I need to tell
the story and if it doesn't make money
I'm okay with that
I think I got past that I think I after
the three films I made which were very
personal films
um I'm kind of over that part
and if there is a story that I really
want to tell I'll write the script and I
think just through that process I've
already like released my creative
um you know outpour
but now I'm definitely
looking into other ways of creating as
well
um like you can make animation movies
with Unreal Engine where you don't need
to worry about
like
getting uh you know millions of dollars
to make this the story that you want to
tell so if you do have a story where
you're like I have to tell it but I
don't have millions of dollars to make
it you can just make it as an Unreal
Engine animation and it actually looks
very realistic that the way that the the
CGI characters are nowadays with the new
release of Unreal Engine 5.
um so that's something I'm actively like
pursuing now